Лише 5 хвилин ходи від мальовничої Одеської опери до моря -
Чорного моря із блакитними хвилями.
Туристи, що приїздять до Одеси,
полюбляють кілометрові пляжі неподалік історичного центру міста.
При цьому Одеса - місто-мільйонник.
Наталя Власенко показує туристам з усього світу цікавинки свого міста.
Як, наприклад, символ Одеси,
що об'єднує старе місто та порт - Потьомкінські сходи.
Тут у 1925 році радянський режисер Сергій Ейзенштейн зняв фільм,
що став класикою кінематографа, - "Броненосець "Потьомкін".
Це не просто сходи, через які можна спуститися в порт.
Це місце для виступів вуличних музикантів, спілкування,
і не лише відвідувачів, це місце полюбляють і одесити.
Лише за кілька кроків від вичепурених будівель старого міста,
відвідувачі можуть побачити зовсім іншу, дещо сонну Одесу.
У внутрішніх двориках вирощують виноград. Час тут не має значення.
На Привозі - найважливішому ринку міста - завжди людно.
Вранці одесити приходять сюди, щоб скупитися у фермерів з околиць.
Це чудове місце, тут великий вибір найрізноманітніших продуктів.
Також це місце спілкування.
Багато хто приходить сюди, щоб порівняти ціни, потеревенити з продавцями.
Саме тому ринок приваблює багатьох людей.
У місті є чимало слідів життя євреїв.
Центром Одеси проходить Єврейська вулиця.
Тут також знаходиться головна синагога, зведена в 1850 році.
Ще століття тому третину населення Одеси складали євреї.
Сонце в зеніті пече безжально.
До прохолоди можна втекти за 40 кілометрів
в Нижньодністровський національний природний парк.
Тут живе багато рідкісних птахів та тварин, як наприклад, рожевий пелікан.
Розмах крил - 3 метри.
Рожеві пелікани полюють групами, тож місцеві рибалки не дуже полюбляють цих птахів.
Якщо приїхати сюди в потрібний час, можна застати цвітіння латаття.
Тут не можна здіймати високі хвилі,
адже серед плавучих пелюстків свої крихітні гнізда будує крячок білощокий.
Справжню одеську кухню можна скуштувати в ресторані "Дача",
де з любов'ю готують місцеві страви.
Тут можна гарно відпочити в тіні - в гамаку чи на розкладачці.
Шеф-кухар Олександр Ковальчук показує нам,
як готується традиційна єврейська страва з оселедцю - форшмак.
Форшмак робиться тесаком або ножем, цю всю масу потрібно рубати,
ледачі господині прокручують все через мясорубку. Це простіше.
Коли ці всі інгредієнти рублені ножем, це відчувається, смак інший.
Головний інгредієнт одеської кухні - риба.
Але найважливіше у ресторані, каже Олександр, спокій. Тоді усе смакує.
Сонце сідає. Спадає спека. Час для останньої прогулянки містом.
Це серце Одеси, найважливіша пішохідна вулиця - Дерибасівська.
Я називаю її Єлисейські поля або 5-та Авеню Одеси.
Це місце зустрічі, не лише для туристів, це популярне місце і серед жителів Одеси.
Ця 5-та Авеню має такий самий неповторний шарм, як і сама Одеса, перлина біля моря.